hey guys what's up we're back this is
date fails I'm Kate quickly we're on all
things comedy and as usual I'm excited
for today I mean I say the same [ __ ]
every week it's like how do you start
this every week I go and I'm excited but
she's been lying up inside but really
I've never been excited until now oh me
too
actually this is really cool because
I've been wanting to have you on forever
yeah just talking about it before the
show I'm like how many times have I said
to you when I see you out every not
every time I see you but like every
other time you're like and you're not on
my ass about it be like hey dude dude at
some point you should get on the thing
I'm like yeah and I'm telling you right
now this is probably the third podcast
I've ever done cuz I was gonna tell you
I don't do pocket I know you don't just
tell me don't do podcast and I was like
I refuse to accept that yeah
just so you know so that you know what
good company you're in I had Katt
Williams on here and it's the only
podcast he's ever that's the band you
know I think he said well it's cuz I'd
like to hit it which I was like I'm okay
with that that's cool whatever your
reason for coming on co-headlined uh
forgot what college was I opened like
yeah I guess I opened forget we both did
an hour but I was first and this is
right before he blew up and he was
hilarious he was such a great character
fun he's so fun he's like I mean I don't
know he's just always on but he comes in
and he had the biggest white fur coat
like he looked like a circle from a
distance it was a huge white circle and
then after the huge so nice he came he
was a yellow man then get on your DVDs
I'm like you know he paid he got in one
of the entourage to pay me and I'm like
I was like dude I'll just give you my
DVD like nah man you gotta you know
Aaron what you you know like thanks man
it was so funny away he was a really
cool guy I like him I mean he's actually
I need to try to get him back because
when I had him on that's when I used to
do this podcast at Jon Lovitz comedy
corner way back before it closed down
which was like three years ago or
something and cat came and did it there
and then when the club closed they took
like all the files from everyone shows
and stuck them in some storage unit
somewhere and then the guy with the key
like quit and long story short I've
never been able to get any of those so
there's all these awesome episodes I'd
like Jon Lovitz and yeah Williams and I
got to get those I'm sorry
no I interrupted your intro to me
everyone's like I was talking on no no
no this is coming now it's fine you know
because this is the thing guys
this guy's a hilarious comic one of my
favorite comics you're so [ __ ] funny
he plays clubs all over the country uh
and he has an amazing YouTube channel
which is really the reason I wanted to
have him on because he gives fantastic
dating and relationship advice real
advice mini orcs
yeah it's real so you got to check out
his YouTube it is youtube.com backslash
Eliot Chang official Eliot spelled in
the most confusing fashion al ot Chang
CH ang official it's Eliot Chang
everyone Amy thank you for clapping for
yourself you make it sound like there's
this twice the audience in here um yay
yeah I love your YouTube videos and we
did one together yeah we did it was on
the flight and because I knew you'd be
good on it because like you're you're
just good on the fly and it's more
authentic that way and I've done that
whether it's girls with its female
friends or girls I'm dating like I don't
you know I just bring it up and if they
go yes I'm like let's do it right now
because I want it to be really authentic
and in the moment I've had that I've had
girls where I'm like hey we had a date
like a first date can you know you want
to talk about and like surprisingly
they're like okay and I'm like alright
great you get to rate me and you can
tell me what I did good or bad and some
great what a risk I mean you'll go out
on one date with a girl and then be like
hey I'd like to put you on camera and
have you talk about the day and they're
not afraid no cuz I don't care cuz it's
like we're not all perfect and I'm like
I'm playing the numbers I'm like look I
think I score high numbers more than
less you know you know so I'm like look
I think it'll be fun and but I don't get
to give the impression I ask every
single girl I go out with every now and
then there's a girl who's clearly open
to it like you already know when you
talk to someone if they're private
person I can tell like they're not gonna
be down for this but I can tell they've
been girls were like I'm totally down
you know I'm like you want em can we
talk about like sex and this absolutely
I don't care and I'm like so when you
know you got someone like that I'm like
I have to take advantage of this yeah
that's true if they're really cool and
open yeah have you ever had a girl that
you went on one date with and then you
were like let's do a video where you
rape me and then she says things that
you're like [ __ ] really like anything
bad absolutely I definitely had girls go
no just immediately I was like uh kind
of Saturday night cuz then they wonder
like wait was that like this whole
premise was based do you go out with me
for hoping to get me on camera no no I
was saying we're having a goal time and
you seemed like you might be open to it
I just miss guests you know and I've
definitely had that oh yeah sure and I
can tell like she's not gonna do it and
then they just disappear and like she
was just getting rid of me just
disappear yeah which is not uncommon in
dating world have you ever had one
though that says yes and then says
things about you on camera that you're
like fog no no I mean actually the girls
that have done it have been very cool I
mean they've definitely been honest and
like hey that was a negative thing that
you did on the date but it but overall
they look overall I had a great time
that's why we're still together you know
but here like you when you did that I
thought that was cheesy er corny or
annoying and I'm alright that's cool
that's no way it's like it's like it's
like a test like as long as it's not
long as I forget like listen addy I'm
fine you know be - yeah means like I did
well 80% of the night that's great I
think that's a great statistic you know
it's kind of fantastic about this - it's
like how many guys get to go on a date
or girls
and then after be like okay and now
we're gonna take a survey of what I did
right and wrong and have someone tell
them like how useful for you I've done
that a bunch of times even before you -
I would do that where if I knew for sure
a girl and I were breaking up you know
and it's usually on the phone cuz they
never want to do it in person I'm really
cool about like I want to break up in
person I want to you know do that face
to face you do i I don't care I I have
no shame I'm not I have very thick skin
it doesn't matter you know it's over so
you never gonna see the person again so
like hey free you know Stewart screw it
like if they show up maybe we'll get to
do one last bang or for sure or it'll
just be like a great for me like even if
it's bad for me it's a great story not
for like YouTube but just for life it's
like it was a great experience like I
like I like horrific things as much as I
like wonderful things because it's you
learn from it but I I definitely those
one time this girl was definitely on the
way to ghosting me and I could tell I
could totally tell so I got on the phone
and I made her admit it and I was I'm
very cool about like being nice about it
I don't go and screamy like look you
know call me back I'm like hey listen um
this is a see this is a practice speech
I've done so many times like hey listen
I'm getting the vibe that I
everything's cool with us you think I'm
a nice person but for whatever reason I
don't think you're really you know dying
to date me again and because you're a
nice person and you think I'm a nice
person instead of telling me that face
to face you're kind of like phasing me
out I mean I'm just kind of thinking
that's what's going on anyway and most
girls if you do it gently most girls are
like yeah that kind of is what's
happening I'm so sorry and I'm like no
no don't don't worry about sorry and I'm
like we just talked it out and a lot of
times we'll end up laughing because I
did break that tension and many many
times I've done this a girl at the end
of conversations been like you know
having this a good time talking like
maybe we should hang up this Friday and
I was like nuts okay I'm like no we're
not I do because I'm like look we're
done it doesn't matter like I'm just
gonna find someone else but I don't say
that what I'm saying is like it's no it
is no point in like yeah I'm gonna drag
you out for one last night because that
that means if that's the case every time
I bring you out I'm gonna have to like
talk you into it
because you were already on the ledge
right me if you're if you're on your way
out that's it's all good like I I'm only
interested in being with someone who's
as enthusiastic with seeing me as I am
with them because the sex is gonna be
better true before the sex just hanging
out it's gonna be fun because like we
both want to be here yeah you're excited
to be there yeah um you're not selling
me I'm not selling you to nowhere we're
beyond that we're just here to enjoy
each other but what I do is I do this I
go I go oh hey so um let me ask you this
so um you know did you ever feel like I
wasn't being a gentleman if I was being
rude or demeaning to you and they're
like no I'm okay and like you know not
to be too forward but like you know I
think the kissing was great for me had
sex I'm like I think the sex was good it
probably would have gotten better over
time as we got to know each other's
rhythms but like with any complaints
there and they'd be like no no not
really you know like okay and like I
mean compared to like other guys you've
met in LA specifically like am i douchey
or my better and they're always like no
you're actually much much nicer you know
because I'm a very affectionate person
like you know you don't seem to be held
back by PDA you're you're very open and
am i all right cool all right well
anyway was great talk to you and I just
get off and then I know they're walking
the walk away going man I think I made a
mistake yeah you get to win you win
they were dumping me but then they walk
away like oh [ __ ] I think I made a
mistake and I always know like I don't
think I've really been done because I
was a dick it's always because I can
tell like a girl's just not ready for
like a big commitment and so they freak
out and they run and instead of telling
you that they just ghost you and the
party's at yeah I do that totally and
the funniest thing is I've never ever
once it to a girl I want a big
commitment I want to be your boyfriend
I've never said that but because I'm a
nice person
they assume that's where it's going and
they don't know I just I [ __ ] bang
around like I don't care you know I can
curse by the way yeah I'm just thinking
in my head about how many times I blown
guys off because I think that they want
more than I do cuz they're just being so
nice and so into me that I'm like this
guy is obviously like falling in love
with me he's gonna want me to commit and
so I start to push them away but now my
head I'm like maybe just being that way
with like five girls at once yes yeah
sometimes it's it's weird sometimes if
you are a nice person it works against
you as a guy like well he's a gentleman
so that must mean he wants marriage and
stuff like that and I'm like that work
that's never coming out of my mouth ever
and you're just assuming that you know
what's so funny is that I was I was
recently dating a guy that I would get
irritated because he wasn't sexualizing
me it was just all about like
conversation and stuff but whenever I
try to like flirty text him or like sext
him a little bit like he wasn't that
into it and he didn't want to have sex
that much and it was driving me crazy
and finally I stopped seeing him because
I was like you know I can't date a guy
that doesn't want to have sex with me
because it's getting in my head there's
something up with me yeah then I started
dating another guy and after like three
or four dates I was trying to really
take my time and like not hook up with
him - I was like really dying - so after
like the third or fourth day he said
something to me like you know so when am
I gonna like when am I gonna see some of
that ass or something yeah and I text my
friend I'm like I'm kind of bummed I'm
kind of turned off because I just feel
like now he's just trying to hit it yeah
and then I was laughing because I'm like
so the guy that isn't sexualizing me I'm
getting annoyed that is not the guy that
is sexualizing me I'm getting annoyed
that he is I'm not sure guys can win no
it's guys can if you just understand the
balance like the first guy went
asexual where you yeah you lost interest
real I guess he's not into me or like
it's too much in my mind like why is he
not touching me yeah and he might it
first of all he might have been doing
the ploy of like look I'm gonna turn
around so much by not being so sexual
with her to the point that she's going
to jump me but it sound like he just
took it too far it's like dude you
should have like stop that a couple of
days in and find like yeah come on over
let's hang out and then boom you know or
and the second guy just went to sexual
it's like it's the balance and what I've
learned is like sometimes I'll be home
PA I won't be non-sexual I will just be
I'll just be calm about it but when
we're behind closed doors I'll
definitely really be an animal so like
when we actually bang I won't be
respectful at all like guys you if you
guys don't you know I it's what I love
the word bang and bone more than thought
that I don't [ __ ] a girl with respect in
your home like thank you everything up
to the close coming up be very
respectful but I say the nastiest
craziest stuff when I'm in bed and I'm
like just tell the girl what to do cuz
show just if you don't want to do it she
really doesn't want to do she like I'm
not into that but any girl who's even on
the fence she'll do it cuz she's like
wow I'm more turned on because he's
taking charge so like maybe I don't like
this position but because he told me to
do it it's a real big turn-on it you
know and I'm not saying guys I'm not
saying like beat women I abuse it what
I'm saying is take charge sexually but
not like in public at a restaurant but
like when the doors are fine too close
totally be an animal and you should be a
complete beast you know oh my god Ellie
all the girls listening right now are
like standing up and applaud you
couldn't be more right I'm in love with
you sadness every girl wants it every
word every girl wants because it's just
natural like except for the specific
who's like no I I personally like to
wear the pants in the relationship I'm
like that's fine but the majority of
girls if they want you to be the man you
know when it comes to you know bangin
like you gotta be really you know take
charge and and so yeah I think the guy
like he just showed his cards too soon
like let me see that ass and like I mean
would I get it because I personally
believe and I've said this too many
times I think it's very important for a
couple male and male male and female
female and female no matter what your
orientation I think it's very important
for you guys have sex
as soon as possible because that is a
huge part of your compatibility now I'm
not saying it's like Hello here's your
coffee let's [ __ ] I'm saying like their
group that's not the play out of the
plant there's so many girls I've talked
to like yeah and I decided to wait to
our third day and there plenty of girls
like yeah I just knew I wanted to bang
you the first night so I had no problem
with it I'm like that's great because
the girls who way think that will extend
how long-term relationship will be and
it won't it won't like if a gret if as
guys gonna be with you long term he will
be whether you bang on the first night
or a month later um personally any girl
who's ever made me wait a month we never
mean got to a month like if I'm still
waiting around a month I've I just move
on to some girl Brent yeah I'm alright
look don't get me wrong I'm not saying
like you know you shouldn't have a
connection personality wise you
shouldn't find out what their interests
are you should but what I'm saying is
when you are both clearly ready to bang
and you're both into it just do it like
you know if you're 16 maybe wait but you
know once you're above 21 there is no
sense in waiting wait a second but wait
a second so this is interesting
I I kind of agree with you because I do
think chemistry is massive and I don't
think chemistry is something people are
like well sometimes you have to have sex
a few times to see if it's good yes but
if the chemistry's not there I feel like
you can't generate it yeah
that being said I think that men and
women are a little different in the fact
that sometimes let's say we hook up
let's say you and I meet we have instant
chemistry I've had this happen with a
couple guys where like we hang out once
I don't [ __ ] him cuz I don't want to
[ __ ] him the first night you know I
already know that it's happening
the second time we hook up the problem
is when the chemistry is so intense that
it's amazing right away a lot of girls
and I do this we start to try to find
other things we have in common such as
you fabricate of relationship exactly so
and I don't feel like men men don't do
that men can be like alright the sex is
amazing unfortunately I don't see a
relationship with this one but I'll keep
banging or but girls we sometimes can't
help when the kid yeah yeah no you're
absolutely right and let's all make an
amendment to my statement cuz you're
right you're right
what I'm saying is so if you're a girl
I'm saying you shouldn't be ashamed of
having sex in the first night if by that
time you're like you know what I'm not
making this my head we do have a lot in
common
you know he's not lying to me I checked
his background and he definitely works
we see works and it is something special
here but yes you're right like a girl
you should definitely not be like you
know I only have chemistry with this guy
and I actually didn't learn anything
else about him but I'm gonna bang him
anyway like that's probably a mistake
yeah I'm saying is when everything else
is lined up you're like I found out
everything I want to know about his
background and the chemistry is there so
instead of waiting a month because
that's the rule we were taught in
etiquette school like I'm gonna bang him
tonight and that's that's totally fine
and you agree by the way I think as
comedians we we have a luxury that other
people don't have and I realized as I
was talking like because as okay as a
guy if you're in show business if you're
a performer you know I probably have
access or the ability to have sex with
women sooner than the guy who works in a
bank or who's like you think so
absolutely because you know uh
performing is an effort you know when
you see someone good at what they do
that's an aphrodisiac but then
especially if it's a performance because
what what we do is we express our
personalities so if they've been
watching you for like an hour they feel
like they already know you so that's why
they can go to sex they can have sex
with you quicker because I already know
this person even those like we just met
tonight for the guys I know totally yeah
a hundred percent the girls feel like
they already kind of know you and
they're so turned on by the fact that
they're gonna hook up with the guy that
all the other girls in the club were
laughing at which is a huge term is
there's a social value to like I'm
hooking up at the star of the night you
know there's a social value to that and
like that's and also that has
handicapped me a lot in real
relationships real and they say like I
prefer to date almost exclusively people
who are not in the business because I
need that realness in my life of like
alright when I'm off stage and I go home
to like my boo whoever it is it's like
we have a real life like we're not out
you know in show business we're just
going to watch a Netflix or go to a
movie and that's really important to me
to be grounded but like I just realize I
do have that advantage because like you
know true you know if your accountant
you can't live the life that we live in
I've been spoiled like so I've had the
ability to just have sex if not the
first night after a show like very like
the second day
at the most girls like saying like I
wanna bang but on week for the second
day but even the second day guys like
wow second day and I'm like it to me
like if a girl makes me way to the third
date I am like over it I'm like oh my
god sorry I know really
I'm over it I don't ever hook up a guy's
in the second date really unless I'm
like crazy attracted to them well the
thing is you know I usually don't see a
girl again unless we are crazy attracted
to each other Oh see I go I do because
I'm trying so hard to like change what
I'm attracted to
I really hey so guess what tonight I
have so much I have so much advice for
you but like I know the perfect place to
do it well okay but there is something I
mean that I will say and okay so to the
girls that are listening I hope they
don't feel like I'm betraying women by
saying this but also we have a lot of
male listeners and there is a secret I
feel that guys can do and maybe it's not
a secret maybe you know we'll see okay
so you have the advantage of you're on
stage and you're being vulnerable and
you're sharing a lot of information and
so they get to know that I can say that
when I have hooked up with guys very
quickly a lot of the time it's because
on the first date the guy will reveal
some very intimate personal information
that makes you feel yes like they really
like you introduction yes yeah like you
know something about losing a parent yes
or something like if you tell a girl
something that seems like a private
personal fact soon into the conversation
it does make girls feel like oh my god
this guy once like this guy really is
into me or he wouldn't be telling me
this we hook up a little quicker guys a
great opening line to any stories you
know I don't normally share this about
myself that works like crazy it's crazy
the key to the door I'm telling you and
by the way I just realized cuz all this
I sensor braggadocious with everything
I've been talking about guys uh anyone
who's watching this like video wise like
I don't I just one you know I don't
think I'm I don't get a lot of girls
because I'm cool I'm not the
best-looking guy I don't have the best
body I'm not the richest guy I'm not the
smartest guy I want you to I want you
guys to know I don't think I'm the [ __ ]
I mean I do and I don't but I don't
think I'm the [ __ ]
what it is is the reason I date so much
is because I go for it you know I always
go for a numbers game it's a numbers
game and I don't and that doesn't demean
the people I end up hooking up with I
just I go most guys but like I don't
think she was into like did you even as
I take a chance you know like at your uh
um when I saw you the other night I try
to hit on your friend she totally stole
mauled me my guts all right no first
time November that I don't escape me she
was standing there but she was hot she
was standing there by herself
and I'm like who is that and I just
walked up by my I don't needle intros I
don't care and I just walked up like hey
here for Kate she's like yeah I'm okay
I'm Elliott just started talking to her
and again like you know she gave me a
standoffish thing which you expect for
the first few seconds when a stranger
approaches a stranger but I said like
hey this is who I am that's how I know
Kate and she kept talking to me and then
you know all I need is about ten minutes
to know if someone's gonna bring down
their guard and I'm like you know you
don't I was like hey she doesn't only
anything I tried was being very polite
I'm like all right well anyway later
just walked away I was like totally
stonewalled me am i it's all good not a
big deal but I went for it but most guys
are like and then she's probably waiting
for a boyfriend oh yeah she's not
interested like dude how do you know if
you don't just freaking go for it a
hundred percent and I always go for it
and also I want to say too that I am of
the opinion and I mean this that no one
is out of anyone's League yeah I always
hear guys use the phrase like she's out
of my league and the thing is it's like
I end up dating [ __ ] a lot and the
reason I think it happens is because
they're the only guys with the balls yes
come on because they you know for
whatever reason I'm friends with a lot
of guys like the other night at my
birthday party has so many guys there
and a lot of guys will see that and be
like oh all those dudes are trying I'm
not even going to bother and so they
won't try won't even try when the truth
is that like those guys are my friends
and if somebody new came up and started
talking to me he'd totally have a shot
and I would talk to anybody and I just
feel like guys shoot themselves in the
foot if they think I mean you never know
because even if you're not the best
looking guy in the room or you're not
the richest guy maybe she just dated
some total piece of [ __ ]
and she's looking for just a nice guy's
gonna treat her well absolutely both
ways I don't care what like the only no
old guys are really listening to is the
no in their own head and that's killing
them it's killing them it's like like
when I yeah we saw the other girl that
night the big tall girl I was like I'm
totally getting a number before I leave
as soon as I saw I'm gonna get her
number and like yeah like that and you
were like hey that girl's really pretty
she could I'm okay I'm gonna I was like
shadow get him gonna owe you no I don't
need your help
but like no I just thought she was ready
yeah she's really pretty and she was
like she was like she was clearly like I
asked her and she's like six feet and
six feet tall I'm 5 8 but I don't care I
don't care I don't care how tall you are
am I then I got a number I think she's
gonna try to come to you yeah absolutely
if you have a video that about tall
women if you're the shorter guy hitting
on it doesn't matter because like I even
talked to the girl but and by the way
this is what I'll do so if it is a tall
girl first I'm gonna totally flirt hit
on them as if I always say like I'm five
eight but I bang like I'm six four you
know and I own that I tell I said I say
that on stage and then I might say it as
a joke if it cuz I won't say that's not
my opening line but if it comes up
jokingly if they bust my balls a guy
you're shorter than me I'm like listen
then I say it but in general what I'm
saying is you should always talk like
you're seven feet tall like I don't talk
like hey thanks for talking to me
because you know I'm smaller agile are
you private 5/8 it's so funny because I
thought you were taller no everyone
thinks I'm 510 or more and I'm like I
think it's cuz got a big mouth and I
come off like I'm bigger and so I was
talking her and as I got to know she
told me she's again my last boyfriend is
5/7 I'm like there we go you know see
exactly so she's obviously open to it
and I we just in by the wait so this was
like subconscious I'm like so I'm
talking about her quote-unquote last
boyfriend but in essence I'm setting up
for the future I'm like yeah because it
doesn't matter four guys five seven five
eight it's about the guy right she was
yeah I'm basically getting to yes and
everything saying and I'm like yeah
because like you know I've talked to so
many girls who said it doesn't matter if
the guy was smaller than me as long as
he doesn't feel like he was a small guy
and I'm like right she goes right so you
know she ever brings it up as an excuse
and I hook up with him like look we
already know you're open to that so shut
up the king of leading girls in lutely
that's what you do you basically just
steer the conversation into whatever
direction you wanted to go
remove all the nose and just hand them
all the yeses you know I have to say
about short guys that no joke when I was
like in high school I was like I'll
never hook up with a guy that's under
like 510 I thought that I had to have
taller guys it was all I was attracted
to and four years and that was married
to a guy that was 6 for 4 years I was
only into taller guys right then after
my marriage one of the first guys that
ended up hooking up with was my height
literally I'm 5 5 he was 5 5 and I was
like this is actually like I was really
into it there was something about like
everything being right at the same
height that I liked and then the next
guy hooked up with it was like five six
and he was the best sex I ever he was so
good in bed and then I started thinking
holy [ __ ] like short guys think they
have to live up to something work way
that's what I started thinking and now
I'm just like I'm really attracted to
smaller guys it turns out like for me I
honestly I do prefer it like if I could
choose a perfect height yeah it's always
been between five zero and five four
because this is a caveman thing but I do
like being much bigger because I like
being able to carry my girl fireman
carry pick her up there and abet I love
to be able to during sex I love being
able to like literally pick a girl up
and spin her around instead of having it
like we heard we've heard it stand up
and turn around M Eliot like throw
around the butler I prefer that but I've
definitely gone out with girls my height
or taller than me and it's just a little
bit different like when I've been with
girls told me like look I can't throw
them around cuz they're physically
bigger it's it I'm not that strong you
know it's so great though when guys are
like that I'm so glad you keep
reiterating this point like I just love
when guys for like I don't like honestly
any time I've gone out with a tall girl
I love walking to a club holding the
hand of a tall girl and like so her head
is above everyone's head and mine but
then they're like they then they see me
with her holding hands like wait what I
had that he [ __ ] yes that's what they
day like she's like a beacon in the sky
cuz she's so tall and I love it
especially if a girl's like I've been
with stalkers I hate you if you don't
want me to put my heels on I understand
like no I'm like put your [ __ ] heels
on I want you as tall as possible if
you're towering over me it's gonna make
me feel good when I'm banging you later
I'm like yeah I took the Amazon down I
don't care yeah
care and I feel like the older you get I
don't know about you but the older I get
the more I'm open to like all different
types and try like I really can feel
since I've hit my 30s like they say
women in their 30s and 40s or at their
sexual peak you're there I can feel it
since I feel like I want to try
everything I wouldn't do everything I
want to experiment with everything which
brings up a great segue is by the way
that I have to mention which is the
podcast has a new sponsor which I'm very
excited about so since we're talking
about crazy wild sex Elliot are you into
like sex toys at all no I've never been
into them just like you know I got the
toy attached to me I don't need anything
else I might have to get you some I
might have to hook you up I may have to
expand your horizons what about lingerie
you know I like girls and lounder
absolutely like I definitely like girls
who put on I've had a few girlfriends
who like they'll surprise with a little
lingerie show that they bought and you
know the god like I bought this and I
like the girl who doesn't like just
bring wear it to bed but like they'll be
like hold on I'll be right back
disappears and comes out and surprised
me much better it's better because I
didn't know it was coming like if it's
in the middle of the day she's like help
me write back and go to the bathroom and
then they come out and you're like whoa
it's a it's such a great surprise middle
the day sex is always a great so it's
great and then lingerie especially well
I bring this up because the new sponsor
on the show Adam and Eve calm which a
few folks don't know they have
everything from lingerie to sex toys to
lube to lotions you can get it all and
I'm really excited because I love all
this stuff by the way if any of the guys
are always thinking you want to you know
send me lingerie I'm happy to wear it go
to adamandeve.com put in the promo code
date da-te just like date fails and you
get 50% off almost everything in the
store 50% off almost everything and you
get three free adult DVDs plus a free
mystery gift and to top it all off we
even throw in free shipping for you on
your entire order so make sure you guys
check it out adamandeve.com put in the
code date it's almost Christmas - what a
great Christmas camp I would love for
someone to buy me like a naughty missus
cause outfit so get that for your girl
or guy or I think it's cool and God I
mean I don't need my guy to be like in
lingerie but I love him guys send hot
photos and like for girl
I got like a guy in like boxer briefs
and no shirt like that's so hot to me
yep do you ever take out photos I you
know I rarely do I've only sent like
maybe one or two dick pics in my entire
life because it's just like first of all
one thing I tell everyone I'm like look
if you're gonna send like a [ __ ] pic or
a dick pic don't have your face in it
just in case just in case you break up
and then BOOM because I agree I don't
care
pictures of my dick get out there if
it's not attached to my face they don't
know it's me
but like no but in general like I don't
instigate that it's always a girl saying
hey you know I miss you send me a pic
I'm like all right so yeah go to when
you're the dude she got a dick pic
because I way more prefer like a hot
photo of a guy with a job it'll be both
again like I'll start off with like
alright fine I'll go to the gym and when
I'm in the gym I'll take a picture but
eventually at the variant I I don't this
is also it's another trick of my like I
don't cuz I don't propose a dick pic I
wait for the girl to ask for because
it's more intense when she gets it so I
just keep it all how about that and then
finally a girl be like dude where's the
dick pic already I'm like all right all
right here really yeah I definitely I
never bring it up you know I just let it
build and I'm like here you go
you know I'm not really a big dick pic
person to be honest but I had one guy
one time send me a dick pic that was
like really hot but what it was so you
guys could do this is it wasn't really
like I couldn't see all of his dick he
kind of like held his shorts out and he
had an erection but he didn't pull it
out so he took the photo down his shorts
and it's kind of shadowy and I could
kind of see it not so it's almost like a
girl sending you like a photo that's not
totally nude but it's like if you lied
it's all the odd dick pics are only
between people who have a they're
already in a serious relationship or
something like that
or they at least been banging for a
while you never send a dick pic hole to
like someone who hasn't even seen you
please god no don't ever do the big
picture should be the first time a girl
sees ur dick you know oh God that's the
worst I never want to see a dick before
she asked for it no um all right I have
a list of your videos that I believe I
thought were interesting so there's so
many things I want to talk about how
about this now I have a feeling I know
what you're going to say but do you
think people should hook up quickly but
do you think the guy should always kiss
a girl on the first date absolutely so
do i absolutely because again it's just
the measure of chemistry and it's like I
was just talking about this the other
day like any girl who's been
yeah I don't kiss on the first date
that's fine you everything I say by the
way ladies no one owes anyone anything
you don't owe me sex right away I'm just
saying I'm used to it you don't only a
kiss on the first night I'm just saying
that's what I go for but if you any
girls been like I don't kiss I've never
been mad I'm like all right that's cool
that's who you are
but statistically any girl who's been
like yeah I don't kiss on the first date
that relationship has never gone
anywhere because not because they're a
bad person but we're two different like
i for you you mean yeah yeah I'm a very
affectionate person and you know I want
to kiss if I'm interested in you I want
to kiss you and see if we have chemistry
because there have been definitely girls
I kissed and immediately like oh [ __ ]
saying we have zero chemistry first this
tells you everything
I think and then also to like so I have
a friend he has a date today actually
and he's like Kate I'm not sure if it's
a date he's like cuz it's a girl that he
kind of works with and he was like we
should hang out and she's like sure and
he goes how do I know if it's a date and
I go easiest way kiss her yeah if she
doesn't let you or if she's like hey
wait I were just hanging out his room I
go if you try to kiss her you're gonna
know right away if she's into you or not
yeah and my just want find out sooner
than later
right instead of waiting around for a
couple of months that's exactly what I
think
and then the other thing too is that if
you kiss a girl at the end of the first
date
this is like the new thing I found I
wonder if you do this first thing you
should do on the second date I think is
kissed a girl of course immediately
immediately because you're reconnecting
them to that memory they had of the
first day and by the way I have a video
about this like I don't believe in
waiting to the end of a date to have the
first kiss whatever it comes up like if
it if an opportunity hasn't come up with
chemistry's not there yet the romantic
chemistry's not there yet to the end of
the day that's why you wait but they're
in so many times like within an hour of
talking to a girl I'm like we're it's on
it's so on and I'll be like you know
I'll just say something like hey listen
brace yourself because I'm gonna kiss
you now you know whatever yeah whatever
I say but I don't wait to the end of the
night because honestly you know what
happens if you wait to like I'm gonna
wait till after dinner after the movie
after the walk it's like that's fine but
live I wait you know if I we meet for
drinks and within 90 minutes or making
out the rest of the night when we go to
dinner when we go to the movie it's even
more fun cuz you're holding hands you're
kissing throughout the night instead of
worrying about am I gonna kiss at the
end of the night it's like know how much
a wienie kiss it's so true and it takes
all the pressure off
sure absolutely know what I think is a
great first day I had this recently and
it's cheesy and it's like so old school
shooting pool I swear to God look we
went to this dive bar we had drinks we
start playing pool it's so great because
you're not sitting across from each
other you're standing you can get close
to each other and we end up kissing
before the date was even over which is
so rare yeah I mean I think it's so
funny because pool is such a guy go-to
thing I love it
no but you get to like walk around each
other and stuff like that the guys
always gonna do that let me help you set
up the shot and like you know get behind
you and do all that [ __ ] of course
and we know and we purposely are like oh
yeah yeah yeah and you push out your
butt a little bit more but like for me
the first date always is let's that's me
for drinks real quick cuz like let's
just talk and because I do that too if
we can't hold a conversation with that
activity for the first 30 minutes it's
not gonna go anywhere anyway and by the
end of it by the time we leave the bar I
know if we're hooking up or not I can
tell like by you know most dates I've
said this so many times if I'm not
making out within 90 minutes then it's
probably not gonna go anywhere it's just
my experience I agree with that you know
how about this you and I shot a video
about not hitting on your friend yes yes
now I want to talk about this because I
do well first of all to remember what we
talked about in the video basically the
gist of it is you said don't hit on your
friend yeah but what if you have a
friend that you catch feelings for you
start to low like front well I think we
touched upon the video only and only if
and you got to be solid sure like if you
know like look it's not just I like my
friend like there's something very
special here and I feel like a real
chemistry in a real connection for like
a future long-term thing that is the
only reason to take the risk on breaking
up that circle of friends because if it
doesn't work out you're absolutely
dividing the friends like a divorce it's
going to happen like people going to
take side and the thing is like most
guys unfortunately actually men and
women both do this most people make the
mistake of you touched on touched upon
it before they fabricate is there a real
connection or do we just like this
person so much I think there's a special
connection and because people like that
big guys do that to guys do that
absolutely like you know I'm like dude
you're just horny and she's hot and she
works in your office it's a big mistake
no no the real connection all right if
you had three
other girls you were casually dating in
more options you'd be thinking more
clearly but because she's your only
option right now and you have proximity
and accessibility at work that's why
you're focusing on this girl and that's
why I'm always telling people like just
to be better to be safe I'm sorry when
in doubt do without just do not date any
of your friends and only any like once
in a while have I met someone in my
friends group I'm like no this is
something I'm gonna take the risk like
[ __ ] it but in general it's not worth
the risk cause you know you all have
options outside of work outside of your
friends you know it's it's such a big
mistake I just think it's such a big
mistake have you when was your last
relationship I haven't ever really like
personal I have no notes
that's fine mice last serious
relationship she was so [ __ ] hot it
was two years ago she was I'm not good I
always I'm very good about privacy and
so I always try to give as many details
without giving too many details but I
can say is uh she was a lawyer not what
she's a lawyer
uh just [ __ ] gorgeous god damn it I
got to stop having memories like and we
had instant chemistry we made out the
night we met I think if we didn't bang
like the second night I mean we had sex
very quickly and then we were ticking
for you and things that was situated for
a year instant chemistry and when I have
that strong of a connection it is not
hard for me to stop dating everyone else
casually it's never been hard to three
serious girlfriends I've ever had when I
make a decision of like whoa this is
someone I wanna get to know and spend
time with it's never been hard for me to
just text everyone else like hey listen
let's take a step back it's fine and and
that's why I'm not fooled into believing
it's a relationship if it's not because
I'm like look I'm always juggling three
or four people so like it gives me
honestly it gives me clarity because I'm
like I'm not doing this cuz I'm horny
I'm doing this because I'm really into
you but yeah I was about two years ago
I've only had like a couple of like a
casual relationship since are you always
the one you said there were three girls
that you like seriously dated are you
always the one to initiate the
exclusivity no it's almost been like
like off by like an hour but it's always
been almost the exact same time that
we're like you know I think we both were
just
acknowledging this is different like
this is not just a regular hook up and
like I remember the relationship I had
before that we both met online or
something like that I forgot what wasn't
match.com lose something and because
there was a time I was on match.com an
OkCupid because I was so busy I was
travelling so much that wasn't hanging
out in bars or clubs I'm like I have no
time to meet people yeah and and I
normally wouldn't meet people in the
street but I'm like or in a store like
no I'm not doing anything supplying
performing and coming home and I [ __ ]
cleaned house on match.com and OkCupid
it was a crazy amount of relationships
back to back but the one girl who ended
it all I remember the first hour first
it was great and by our second date I
didn't tell her this because I'm not
going to freak her out but by the second
date I just took my profile off mass
comm whatever was I'm like yeah I don't
I'm not going to meet other people and I
was with that girl for a couple of years
no way you knew after two days I knew
after two days I honestly knew after the
first date but I'm like let me just just
be careful let me just wait for a second
and she admitted to me later she's like
yeah honestly I knew no way I choose and
I know she was JIT it's been kind of
casually dating someone too she's like
yeah I'm not dating one else I mean
either because we were both like um
we're both kind of like not party people
but we're both dating other people at
the same time but when we both met each
other we both are like yeah I'm not you
know I'm done with everyone else it's
just gonna be you and me see this is
interesting because you are I've known
you for a while and I've known you not
to really be a quote relationship yeah
although you had them but I mean like it
to me in my mind you're a guy that dates
a lot of you I have the ability to like
it's almost sociopathic but I can turn
on a switch of like click yeah I don't
miss I'm not because I but you're
missing out on all these other girls I'm
like it doesn't suck I'm fine it doesn't
matter I've had plenty of fun yeah but
the thing is that that's fascinating is
that means guys if they like you enough
will do it if they like you enough yeah
because I mean I know I've met a lot of
guys especially recently that have this
thing about putting a label yeah thanks
guys always say like oh everything is
cool till you put a label on it like I
even had a guy that I could tell was so
into me was calling me every day you
want to hang out all the time and then I
was the one that brought up like you
know I think I'd be kind of bombed if I
found out you were seeing other people
and
the minute I he was like oh I don't do
labels I don't do lazy I don't wanna and
I I've heard that from guy friends too
and I'm just like so when guys are like
I don't want to do labels it just means
they don't like you enough don't you
think
um it could be that I think half a time
it is that reason but the other half
it's like even if they're really really
into you they're just not mature enough
to like deal with a commitment thing
which is I understand what a commitment
it's a big fear for guys they don't
admit although I'm fine
I think it's fine to be old okay I think
it's totally fine to me mature enough to
say yes I fear commitment it's an issue
I'm working on it but that's where I am
right now it's okay
you know yeah that's true but most guys
won't admit that so they'll say that oh
no believe in labels and I personally
you know 20 I don't believe in labels
either but I don't care for girl uses
label I'm like look I don't care if you
want to call me your boyfriend or
whatever you want to call me I'm not
gonna tell you not to say that what I'm
saying is like uh because I grew up in
Harlem but like what if you're not her
boyfriend what if you're just dating
casual I don't you're my boyfriend
I'm like look I if you want to call me
that I can't cuz you know why cuz I
can't control what you do anyway so when
we're not together you're gonna say that
and I think I really don't usually say
girlfriend like you know I just say like
I think it's the hood in me and I guess
my girl that's it that's actually wait
wait wait wait wait but so if you're
with a girl who's not your girlfriend
and you're at a party and she introduces
you to her friend as my boyfriend Elya
here that doesn't bother you no I don't
care I'm like you want to say that I
don't care it doesn't matter I'm not I
don't have a lot of hang-ups I'm not a
jealous person
I don't care guys like wait so this
girl's gonna [ __ ] their pants and run
out of the party maybe like what did she
say but I'm gone that's it
all i care is the only things that I
wanna hear out of her mouth is yet we're
not banging anymore that's the only
label I don't want to hear that's a guy
not banging anymore if she says that I'm
like we got an issue you want to call me
your [ __ ] husband in four different I
don't care you know what it doesn't
matter to me crazy because I know what
the truth is I'm like whatever you look
girls and men but girls are just insane
and look whatever you need to say to
yourself to make yourself happy I don't
this is why girls are insane just so you
know because let's say that we're dating
and I introduce you as my boyfriend
apparently somewhere along the way I got
in my mind that you're my boyfriend
but you're saying in your mind
you might be like I'm not her boyfriend
but you can call me that but I'm still
banging two other girls yeah that could
mean you're on totally different playing
fields no no I mean okay what I'm saying
is if she knows I'm not her boyfriend
but she just feels like calling me that
that's fine
if I think she's deluded like hey crazy
yeah if she's deluded like hey so this
is my future fiance I'm like I'll be
like hey all jokes aside you don't
really think that do you and she's like
on I'm just joking around but no I know
what you mean okay so if a girl goes I'm
you're is my boyfriend if I don't think
she's joking around
I'll pause I'm like hey listen I don't
want you saying that whatever to get you
over you're forgetting you know you know
I do tell me you're not letting all
these girls I'm imagining like all these
girls running around LA like yeah Elliot
Chang's my boyfriend and they all think
it for real first of all I think most
girls because I'm a comic think like oh
he's not gonna get serious it's it's
either already either miss guessed
either think I'm definitely serious I'm
not serious at all and again I don't
care it doesn't matter because
statistically if the girl had the same
amount of Trant she has the same amount
of you know probability of disappearing
on me no matter what so it doesn't
matter
oh she disappeared because I wasn't
serious enough oh she disappeared
because I was too serious it doesn't
matter so I'm like look if you gonna
disappear I'm gonna go out to CVS
pharmacy and run into another girl and
start dating her tonight it doesn't
matter you know um interesting yeah I
know I'm a sociopath all right
no I swear to god okay I showed you I am
a great okay you know actually if you
know you know what you're not a
sociopath or we would a bang bind I know
it is that's my time this is the thing I
am a great boyfriend but probably not
the best person at date because I'm not
gonna I'm gonna drive you crazy because
I'm not gonna be like a typical guy so
you're not gonna be control me and
manipulate me the way you'd want to so
probably a nightmare to date because
girls don't have any power but I'm a
great boyfriend because once I commit
I'm like you're gonna feel like a queen
24/7 there's no like when guys like
aren't you worried about she's gonna
meet up with her ex-boyfriend had lunch
to catch up I'm like if she was gonna
bang another guy she's gonna bang
another guy all I can do is bring what I
bring to the table if I'm not taking
care of business behind closed doors
she's gonna bang someone else anyway I
can't lose my mind every night about
that like I think I'm a great catch I
think I'm nice to you I think I treat
you well if you want me if you want me
to eat you out for an hour I do it if
you want me to I'm not into ass you want
me as play I'll do it whatever you need
me to do I'll do it so if you meet a guy
you can do if you meet a guy who can
offer you more than
I can offer you you should [ __ ] go be
with them like you know so what you're
saying basically is you're hard to get
but you're great to have yes they get
you once they get me absolutely I even I
think all three girlfriends if I had
them here they'd be like yeah he was
great
I don't be sure you I don't you are a
great guy you're very sensitive very
kind I don't think you're really a
sociopath at all I can't I just have a
you notice no sociopath
I'm able to compartmentalize emotions
and that drives people crazy so well
that drives women crazy because we can't
yeah hey my fault that is like what's
the reason men like tits cuz they don't
have them yes we can't
I've truck trust me when I tell you I
have tried to compartmentalize and it is
almost impossible it's hard for women I
feel that really hard even like recently
I had a fantastic booty call going this
guy is so hot he's so good in bed and as
long as I didn't know him too well or
like it yes much it was fine and then
you know what happened I got to know him
just a little too well and it's not that
I caught feelings it's the OP heard me
off yeah I can't [ __ ] it like this is
why I'm banging this whole time I've
been banging this around this whole time
dammit yeah I was so Satan about under
the less you know is better oh I don't
want to know anything what if I find a
guy that's a booty call yeah I had one
that was so perfect we literally would
only text for sex and send dirty photos
and we would hook up and that was it
yeah and that's all I wanted it to be
and then eventually it just ended
because like it just got to complement
its gonna run its course anyway booty
calls can only go for so long yeah it
can only last so long yeah for sure
um this is one more interesting topic
that I want to bring up because this is
something that just happened to me and I
think this probably is a scenario that
many men have been in so we can speak to
this so you came to my birthday party
the other night
by the way I want to say this you look
you know it's really funny you looked
great but I mean you always look great
but I was gonna say this I forgot to
tell you that night because it was just
such a busy night but like you looked
very beautiful but very classy beautiful
because most girls on the birthday are
gonna hooch it up and not that we both
know it's not like you don't have
hoochie outfits but thank you no but
what I'm saying is for a birthday for
Hollywood birthday in LA you expect like
I'm gonna [ __ ] totally horde up but
uh you know you look like a very classy
lady of like oh this is like the
Princess of Monaco
nice or something oh my god it was
unexpected well you know why to be fair
the reason is because earlier that day
I'd posted a video of me ballet dancing
on Instagram so I thought to myself I
can't post that video and then also look
[ __ ] tonight you have to class it up
now to make it look like I'm you know
only a [ __ ] at the ballet class so but
thank you
which is by the way probably very
confusing for the guys you did because
if they follow you on social media and
then you're such a classy girl cuz it
okay so that's a thing before you get to
it you're gonna say I'll just hit this
bring that alright I think one of the
biggest obstacles you have is that you
have such a great career like because
you have such a great social media and
comedy act and all this stuff
unfortunately in this day and age it's
hard to tell a guy like hey listen let's
go out but don't don't look me up on
social media - after our first day yeah
you know and the thing is because most
guys can't separate the character of
like Kate the performer and Kate the
person because what I know of you is
that you are a very sweet classy person
you know when it comes to being when
you're in a real interaction but guys
are going to assume the performance Kate
is who you are and then because of that
they're going to tweak their
personalities to match that so when they
show up it really is a formula to not
have a long term relationship because
they're looking for like where's party
Kate dancing naked and you're like
where's my prince charming who's gonna
treat me like a normal person right and
that's that's where the conflict comes
like a lot of times I'll tell girls like
you know I won't tell them that I have a
big social media presence I'll just
mention I'm a comedian and just move on
from that and because I've had girls say
like you know show up on the first day
like yes so I looked you up online so
you do all these videos of picking up
girls is that what you do and so it
takes me like 20 minutes to defuse that
situation and I do I'm used to I'm like
listen yeah that's what I did but that
was before I met you and you can tell me
you don't make me guys at bars before
you met me it's just on camera that's
the only difference
everyone has a history and in public
yeah it is definitely in show business
is different that's why when I meet guys
that aren't on social media I'm that's
the best for you I can't mishil
immediately I'm like let's get to know
each other and I mean it is hard but I
don't know yeah I know what you say um
so
ok so I have my birthday party yes the
other night yes now I felt like I was on
The Bachelorette at my broker party okay
so I'm at the party I had invited a guy
that I'm interested in we've been on
just a couple dates uh but we have not
hooked up by the way you well you said
this the other two every time you say
there's like to me if there's no
penetration it's not a date but go ahead
you're hanging out yeah we didn't hook
up okay that then at least that's still
a date but go ahead
all right fine so there's one okay then
my friend invited another one who I've
been out with a couple times as well who
I also haven't slept with and he came
now I warned this guy I was like listen
just so you know I'm being really
distracted at my party a lot of people
there I won't be able to give you you
know undivided attention you don't know
anyone they're kind of basically was
trying to get him to like not come yeah
pretty much but he came anyway he's
doing I'm of course ago so now they're
both there then two other guys show up
that I've made out with but I haven't
had sex with any of these people which
is good okay but what I'm curious about
just from a guy's perspective is what I
noticed is the less I gave them all
attention the more they kind of tried of
course and the guy that one was sort of
the guy that came hung out about an hour
stayed back a little bit and then left
and then text me later like hey let's
hang out soon yeah the other ones kind
of seemed like they were hanging out
waiting like it's gonna be the last guy
at the party and then eventually they
all left and none of them got the rose
Yeah right
but what I want to know is have you been
the guy in this scenario like do you
think they all knew and what do you
think the product play is I think they
could definitely first of all as a guy I
would have assumed I'm just assuming
like look it's her birthday if we're
casually kind of hooking up there's got
to be some other guys here I don't know
who they are but there's got to be at
least one of the dude here that she's
doing that with because like look at her
like you know I'm gonna sue I'm the only
one she's casually absolutely and then
also guys can sense it but like all
right look at me what do I look like is
there any other guy that has my vibe not
but you know not that you look exactly
like me ethnically or style wash belly
is there any do I see any in
vidual guys here is like this guy's here
by himself he's not with their peck of
friends he doesn't know any of her
friends so he's a solo I'm a solo I
think he and I are both hooking up with
her oh there's another dude standing by
himself I mean that's what I would say
out absolutely soon but it's okay
because I only feel weird about if I'm
like well we've already been banging for
a while so are you still hooking up with
the sky they just just let me know but
none of them can say anything it's like
look we only made out at your birthday
everyone's here okay would you invite a
girl like if you were having a birthday
party would you invite more than one
girl that you've been seeing I never
invite any girls to my birthday party
what I never invite any girls any girls
no absolutely not because only if it's
like well this is the girl we're really
starting to really see each other so
obviously I want you to be there but if
it's girls I'm just casually dating like
no I don't I don't all three of them to
show up and have to deal with that so
I'm like no I'll just tell them like hey
you know um I'm hanging out my friends
on my birthday but how about like the
day before like you me do something just
free you and me but I'm like no I don't
have to deal with introducing three
separate women to all my different
friends I don't have to deal with them
like meeting each other like wait what
you wait you're meeting wait you're
dating Elliot Italy I don't deal with
any of that um like I don't I don't care
and it's like oh don't you get laid on
your birthday like I don't care it's so
funny that you bring that up because
when a guy invites me out with him and
his friends like I had a guy invite me
to a birthday and I was the only girl
that he invited okay and then I met his
buddies whatever and then in my mind
that kind of meant like oh this guy's
really into me like he introduced me to
his friends invited me to his birthday
whatever then I was really surprised
when I found out like he still was like
very casual about the whole thing right
and then as a girl here's the thing I
get embarrassed as the girl cuz then I
feel stupid cuz then I'm like oh how
embarrassing if I'm just like the girl
they met Wednesday then Friday there's
the girl they met and that's Sunday
there's the girl they met so I just
think I should not introduce you to
their friends unless they're serious
about absolutely you agree I absolutely
agree thank you if you happen to meet my
friends by coincidence because we've run
into them or something I'm not gonna be
like I'm not gonna introduce you right
well I don't go out of my way to be like
yeah come over for Thanksgiving dinner
my family absolutely not because I'm
sorry like it takes a couple of months
for a girl's meet my friends or whatever
what's embarrassing to you make the girl
look like an idiot
cuz the girl then then the next time I
meet your friends again they know like
oh she's number three and rotations
I know embarrassing their guys I have
friends who date as much as I do so they
know like I'm not gonna put a lot of
time in the meeting like they bring a
date to a party I don't put a lot of
time into meeting her I'm polite but I
don't really get to know her because I'm
like look I know the deal she might be
come next week I don't have the time to
meet every girl you bring in here so
yeah the flip side of that though is I
always bring a guy out to meet my
friends as soon as I think I'm into him
at all and that's because if the girls
friends don't like the guy that's a deal
breaker that I don't really care as got
no guys don't care cuz like I'm still
gonna bang the broad I don't care I'm
gonna bang this broad yeah I've
definitely had two girls show up on the
same night to something accidentally
like you know I didn't know it was a
comedy show no it wasn't a comedy show
but it was it was an event and like one
girl I was kind of seeing and the other
girl I was seeing like a little bit less
and I did kind of like casually mention
it but I didn't I didn't think it
registered with either of them you know
what I mean so like it wasn't I didn't
know there was a chance
and so one showed up at school when shut
up and literally once sitting down and I
happen to be looking over a shoulder to
the door and then the other girl walks
in the door I'm like okay oh [ __ ] this
is a small this is a small like room how
did you feel I felt my heart drop at my
birthday party oh [ __ ] now what do I do
like okay my first go to my head is like
alright listen if it comes out it comes
out I don't know I don't know any of
these girls anything but let me see if I
can avoid that happening and I just just
kept them on different sides of the room
and just kept bouncing around and just
waiting for what and I was like yeah you
should take off because I'm gonna be
here for a while buh-buh-buh-buh you
know and then and then that girl took
off and then the other girl stay which
is fine but then this is crazy but then
that's same night so the one girl stayed
who actually really wanted her to stay
she stayed but then there was a
different girl who I didn't know when I
met that night who was like a fan of
mine I guess
and that girl started following me
around the club and was like hey like
and she's like hey listen so like we
should leave like you know I live down
the street we should hook up Oh bah bah
bah bah and like no no let's go and I
just kept it very cash
like nah now you know I'm here with some
friends and that and finally Ida Beck
listen because the girl is literally
like circling like I would cross the
room she crossed but still listen
seriously let's go hook up and like
listen at a corner but look and I used
the word girlfriend just to say like
look I actually have a girlfriend and
she's here right now so you know I don't
want any drama so like we should just
not you know talk anymore buh buh
and it goes like listen I don't give a
[ __ ] if you've got a girlfriend like I
can just give you my address I'll leave
now just meet me late and we'll bang you
know and I will tell her you know and I
was like look an honest s like now
because also because by that time I felt
like this girl's kind of psychotic so
most likely yeah most like not a fan yet
you gotta be careful a fan that's what
I'm saying sounds like you know it's
it's too many red flags like no no no
and then I got into a little bit of
trouble I guess cuz then the the girl
who was there was like who was that
who's that girl who's following you
everywhere I saw she cornered you at the
bar what the hell was that about
and I was like hey that wasn't me like I
didn't invite her and I got rid of her
like I got rid of her for you like yeah
you know I didn't bring you know I
didn't that's the worst as a guy when
you're trying to do the right thing yeah
I'm with the girl and then the girls
like who the [ __ ] is that but it's it
come on I just turned down sad yeah look
away that wasn't planned like I didn't
yeah they come here she cornered me in
this and that and that calm down it
didn't matter like it also moved that
but I've definitely had that happen it's
not it's not an ideal situation but when
in doubt guys male/female like you can
always just tell everyone go [ __ ]
themselves and walk out the door I think
that's a great note to end on when in
doubt tell everyone to go [ __ ]
themselves
yeah perfect dude you were such a great
guest I feel like I could talk to about
the ship for I have so much you know
next we'll do another I have so many
like it's funny we didn't really do need
eight fails I know I kind of do have a
horrible dates
I have something to happen this weekend
it's a lazy please tell me I can fit
this in all right Ellis you know I
wanted to get your opinion on this
because great cuz um I think I'm in the
right and Kate's usually a solid like
trooper like Kate's a soldier in the
sense that like she can separate being a
woman and just give me an honest opinion
and I like to take the side of a woman
just because you're a woman yes it's
true
alright here that here the bullet points
again I'm gonna try to protect the
innocent
alright met this girl in June
tall debt like six foot
European lady beautiful gorgeous and we
met we hit it off right away and we
immediately just spent the week she was
only visiting because she was visiting
from Europe we immediately spent the
weekend together in her hotel it was
great and we just we hung out we banged
I sure town like you know at night we
bang during the day we go around what a
great time and it was really cool
because it was a very subtle
understanding of like look we're only
here for this you're only here for this
weekend and even when I said I'll drop
you off at the airport like I got a car
so even I dropped her off I was like hey
listen you know I don't know what I'm
gonna see it she cut me off she's like I
know I got cuz I was like I don't I
don't know when I'm gonna see you and
she's like look I know it was great
meeting you like you know keep in touch
we have whatsapp we can message every
now and then and you know if I'm ever
back in the States and you do favor come
to Europe i'ma get absolutely it's like
you know every few weeks we just like
message hey how are you this and that
just keeping it light every now and then
do a phone call how are you you know
yeah she ends up getting a job in the
States a couple of states away I'm gonna
say this again I'm trying to try to
protect it but in a different time zone
so this weekend okay we were trying to
figure out the times and I finally had a
free weekend and so this weekend I went
to visit her okay now again you don't
owe me anything you don't owe me
anything cuz if you know just because we
bang before it doesn't mean you owe me
you don't have to bang again doesn't
mean you have to make out sure but I
personally believe if you're the girl
and you're thinking that's off the table
you should let the person know before
they come to town just so they know like
hey just let me know like I started
dating someone I don't see you yeah you
know but I was like whatever and I cuz I
basically obviously long story short
over the weekend like we didn't bang we
barely made out we just fun stay with
her and ice the things it's weird isn't
I stay in a hotel where she's staying
and like cuz her job put up in a hotel
right now and like we slept in the same
bed you know we made out a little bit
everyone no sex and I'm like look you
don't owe me she say why no that isn't
thing she didn't say why and so this is
this is how it went the first thing I
got they're like I bet her at a club
she's there with her friends and I got
there really happy to see me hugging me
like oh my god it's so cool you're here
that night when we back like to replace
him you know of course I might and I'm
like well statistically this is where
we'd be
you know because I haven't seen you in
six months yeah but even on the ride
home look we're holding hands in the car
and she's like you know she's dropping
the hints like you know I'm really
really tired I'm like alright fine I
guess she's not the mood to bang tonight
fine I'll see what happens I'm in my
head I'm like I'm still gonna try to
make out with you because I just wanna
at least kiss you and if that turns you
on enough that you wake up well bang but
if it doesn't I'd be happy with just
making up because I haven't seen you in
a while get in the bed and so she's like
hey she hugs me again I'm really happy
to see you so I start kissing her a
little bit we start making out a little
bit and then she's like look I'm really
tired I'm like cool cool you know but
normally huh normally any time a girl
said that she's always said hey I'm
really tired but I swear to god I'll
bang you in the morning like a girls
always said that she's like hey I have a
headache but I swear to God
when I wake up will bang in the morning
but she was like hey I'm really tired of
Mike okay okay no worries spent the next
day together walking around you know and
every now and that went to the mall
walking around you know shopping
chilling out every now and then I got
leaned over to kiss her but it was kind
of like a cold fish kiss and I'm like
okay we're very weird very weird and
then um I didn't plan any shows in town
and she was like hey you know I'd really
like you know I haven't seen you onstage
since I met you I would love to see you
do a show and I'm like all right so I
contacted a club and I was like hey I'm
in town here my credits can I get up and
they're like yeah come on over we give
you a spot and so but as the day went on
she's like you know because we're
supposed to go to a party that night
she's like you know what I don't think
there'll be enough time to go home
change and go to the club so wanted to
go to the club I'll go home and change
and we'll meet at the party I'm like
that's fine totally fine and I go to
kiss her like you know because we're
about to separate so I go to kiss her
and then she gives me the cheek and I'm
I know right so we're like this close
and she turns and I'm like [ __ ]
that's absolutely deliberate there's
something going on here ask okay so by
the time I got back from the show on set
this was Saturday night um she texted me
she's like hey listen whenever you're
done with the show just come home
because I'm actually not feeling well so
I'm not gonna go to the party I'm like
that's cool I got home and she's
sleeping I'm like alright well I'm not
gonna [ __ ] jump someone when they're
sleeping so the next day I honestly by
this time I'm like over it because I'm
like you should have told me what's
going on and normally that is the point
why be like listen you don't owe me
anything but like clearly yeah you
a plane ticket came all the way there I
have a history of banging one gang over
the course of time between when you guys
first hooked up and when you saw her
this time and you were texting and
talking was there sexting was there any
flirty texting was but it would come and
go so sometimes it'd be a lot of flirty
60 like maybe she was seeing someone
great God we just got fine oh just tell
me you know like you could have even
told me like before I got on the plane
like all right well that's kind of a
disappointment but I'll still hang out
still cuz she's still a cool person yeah
by the way this person is a awesome
person yes something was off and on
Sunday I was over I'm like you know what
I'm not gonna even like I normally be
like what's going on I'm like you know
I'm over it like I'm not even attract or
do anything she's gonna have to like
come to me and she would sleep her that
night she's like I'm gonna go sleep
early I'm like okay and I was like night
I wasn't even like an accord anything
but it's funny I think by the end of the
last day I think she started feeling bad
like hey you coming to bed I'm like no
I'm gonna watch TV for a little bit and
it is a stronger girl than me because I
would have at least had like pity sex at
that boys I felt so guilty about it and
then I left and I don't I don't normally
condone ghosting someone I don't but
this is all the situation's I'm like you
know what I don't think this person
would even understand where I was coming
from like I think she just get very
defensive and I'm like you know I'm just
gonna ghost this person for a couple of
months because I'm sure I'm getting like
text messages okay you get home okay and
like I don't I don't feel like dealing
with it and I'm sure in her head she's
like I don't understand while he's not
getting in touch it he has to know right
and then the worst thing is that as a
girl there's part of her that's probably
like oh so he just wanted to bang me
which is totally unfair this is what I
this is what I you think okay but it is
okay here's what I think I think there's
someone else obviously that she's like
really into maybe in love with who knows
and they're probably not together or I
wouldn't have had you come out right
they're probably like an on and off kind
of thing and they're off or they broke
up and she's not over him and she
thought she would have you come out cuz
she she was enjoying the attention you
guys were flirty texting and it was a
distraction and then when you got there
she realized she wasn't like ready to
bang your feel about what she will know
yet
whatever I think that's probably what it
was but she didn't want to tell you
because maybe part of her was like well
but he's a good guy and I might want him
at some point I think but the only thing
that's weird about that is that most
girls in that situation once you're
there especially did she drink at all
you guys drink yeah a little bit cuz
usually most girls in that situation
would hook up with you to try to help
get over whatever that situation is and
also you guys [ __ ] the last time and we
[ __ ] a lot and it was good yeah it was
a really good way yeah that is a weird
one I was like look I could I could
totally understand if it was like a
blind date we've never met yet and she's
like well I wasn't comfortable yet but
I'm like look we've already been like
I've already been inside you understand
with it now that's a really weird one I
don't think I've ever I I did recently
have something happen with a guy that I
did used to hook up with and then we
went out one night recently and I did
not go home with them and I specifically
did it to make a point because I felt
like when we were dating before as soon
as we started [ __ ] he stopped ever
taking me out right and so I was trying
to show him that he needs actually make
an effort do me out but this is totally
different
I've only had this happen once in my
ever my other in my life ever it
happened one other time and I swore like
I will never put myself in a position
again I'm flying out to see someone I'm
not hooking up because again I think
it's a woman's responsible actually if a
man flew in a woman he should tell her
ahead of time like listen I just want to
know I started seeing someone so I just
don't want to mislead you what might be
happening but if you say nothing and
someone's flying in that you've already
had previous I totally agree I think
it's misleading it's very misleading I
couldn't agree more I really think it's
I think it's rude and again if some
girls like she doesn't owe you sex she
doesn't owe me sex no she doesn't owe
you sex but she at least owes you an
explanation if things change drastically
so where now she's not even kissing you
that's the thing like I would have been
fun like it would be okay for at least
like being intimate and holding hands
and kissing she's like I can't bang this
I got my period I'm really a date fail
though that isn't it is it so that's why
I was like you know what I actually have
a date fail for you so that was it like
here's the thing and I say it on it all
the time on the show and it's easier
said than done but sometimes honesty is
the hardest thing but for everyone in
both circumstances it's like
ripping off a band-aid quick it's like
it's like this guy that I've been seeing
like I'm gonna have to tell him I'm just
not really feeling it with you sometimes
it's just it's like putting down an
animal it's the humane thing to do
that's a great thing there's a humane
medium to do it I've seen so many times
at the very least yes you're right
confrontation is horrible at the very
least men and women just type that out
of text and just send it just yeah and
that's run off your phone yep but just
send them a piece of information saying
look I'm not gonna ghost you but you're
not gonna see me again
and this is why goodbye that's it yeah I
didn't block their number and also
[ __ ] stick with it [ __ ] because
I'm one of those girls that like then
you get lonely and drunkies want little
attention so you hit up the poor guy
that you know hit you back don't do that
okay once you cut them off delete the
number gone all right I'm mic drop I'm
done mic job this has been date fails
this is a great episode I feel like this
was very informative you're fantastic
everyone should go check him out on
YouTube he is awesome it is youtube.com
backslash Eliot Chang official Li ot you
watch me hit on strange girls you can
watch him hit on strange girls we should
go out sometime and hit on people
together and record it give each other a
bit and you guys know you can follow me
at cake cue funny on everything and make
sure you check out Adam and Eve comm
please use my discount code date da-te
Adam and Eve comm this is a blast please
come back again sometime
alright cool see you guys next time bye
[Music]